hello welcome to the CDO playing krutov
ok continue to practice some of my
English opening repertoire so let's see
how it goes one b6 yeah it's interesting
learning and ce4 that i have played
myself quite a bit ok never didn't like
that with them a double fianchetto is he
going for looks like is going for an
hippopotamus some kind of cell now a
sammich it's not bad against this not
bad at all so we'll see what he is
coming up with here 86 ok you know this
is part of the hippo part of the hip was
set up maybe I can just do something
here
why not take some space if he thinks he
can do without space on my grab some
maybe see 5d 5v5 something like that is
what he's up to no I can still do that
okay so
it should be 392 I mean probably I
should just play quickly what I'm
thinking a lot of stuff like yeah this
dc5 d 595 maybe this is something
bothersome yeah for is hanging okay
after 35 I mean f3 you're saying is what
I was trying to say
yeah yeah this is why I was a little bit
hesitant about um Bishop d3 92 it's not
clear that this is so cool um yeah
threatening on f3 here I don't like the
smell they are probably over expanded
we're trying to punish it set up I
played it a little bit to lose ok meet
this one try to pressurize e6 now you
can just take twice now that hoods
getting this bad position against this
opening ok now you can take d3 be 20 in
a half no King position
yeah a four you can probably take the
bitter taken you take the bishop and
night c4 is also coming i feeli could
have punished me harder it's still not
good but okay this is probably a good
move
still not easy to to play for me but I
think em again I think he had ways to
make life more difficult for me I
applied that opening far too loose I
mean I really think the heck bottomless
is pretty dreadful if white has see
foreign but it's not it cannot be
punished with that crude play that I am
that I am then I went for him let's get
rid of that night
what okay takes bishop jakes ok ok i
have Bishop f4 we said oh is that
working for him Bishop everything I
don't check now this I didn't I kind of
saw that this is possible but didn't
think it would work probably it does ok
is pretty dangerous
hey I should have taken a turn by the
way yeah what is he doing this one hmm I
can tick I can teach you forward don't
think it will work now it's got its got
some some material here
there is no immediate threat at least I
don't see it but my coordination is poor
time learning takes Bishop takes Queen
dear phone chicks chicks check maybe
that deep pond is today is too dangerous
ruki one Queen f6 was my idea maybe this
is just a draw it what this feels very
scary check maybe it's not at all like
you can check me there no okay check
it's very difficult to play for with him
I've no turn check check Crean age to
check
check glad check forfeits on time Carrie
lost some time ok so note to self I mean
don't you be too relaxed again sirs I
mean I think I'm kind of okay up to here
grabbing that space cannot be so bad but
I have to plea be more more more exactly
with placing those but ok probably
objectively speaking I shouldn't just
play h3 but develop normally when black
just has a pretty bad position it's got
no space and he cannot attack the center
easily the same ish is really a good
replying answers and so yeah I think I
have to improve somewhere here to not be
that overextended probably have to
cancel long here or something like that
this is already getting getting shaky
very shaky on yeah this is losers
according to the engine after he takes
and not castles just me takes here is
pretty dreadful yeah my opposition is
very weak now the center collapses so i
was really a pretty awful opening play
yeah here he went here probably not bad
check but this looks awful really awful
I mean maybe this what takes him I mean
what kind of King is sad the engine says
I'm losing somehow I mean it's still bad
according to the computer I'm kind of
hanging on a little bit at least
yeah this smooth seems to work according
to the engine it wants to play Bishop g1
no with an advantage Isis to draw it
seems check the drawer I was I wanted to
do this the engine gives a draw Queen f5
okay so if I'm take it check black will
actually win now my my king is open now
Bishop c4 is a draw check and check
check and this doesn't work because I
can take it I didn't really consider
taking it looked just really dangerous
to me check but the computer doesn't
show anything here yeah that's true so I
should have taken it and hear a blanket
still better but of course so it's it's
tough to play in this time justice is
correct no no I'm winning and now Queen
f4 was winning not Queen f6 because of
the check yet this is stronger I also
have this okay that would have won the
game tracker here there's also wins I
can and check we have a piece up you
just write a CH pawn it was difficult to
coordinate check check yeah it's still
winning right to the ends but yeah so I
shouldn't play this kind of loser again
sg4 h4 not a good idea okay well that's
thanks for watching